hello hello so nice to be
here drew you look so beautiful
because i'm wearing your beautiful
empowered because you're wearing your
heart
outside that's fine i do wear my heart
outside my sleeve and i just
feel so lucky to be kicking off
international women's day
with you and you created the dvf
awards in 2010 to recognize
extraordinary women
what motivated you to start doing this
amongst all the other things you were
doing but really focus at an awards
ceremony and
and well it's my son
he said you know the family foundation
since you care so much about women
you should organize an award so that we
can donate
money give support and exposure to these
extraordinary women
that people don't know and i know you
have a guest today that
reflects exactly that that's exactly
right
in 2014 a woman named veronica scott was
honored with the dvf award
and she's been paying it forward ever
since
um and she's actually here right now
veronica hello
hello thank you for having me hi
veronica i knew veronica
when she was just a little girl and
veronica
is is a wonderful example for me
and we've stayed in touch and we are
friends
right veronica yes it i have to say that
first night i met you it was like
floating
i couldn't believe it was really
happening and you know that was like the
first big recognition
you know i had gotten but also
empowerment plan had ever received so
this was
huge for the organization and for me and
it's i'm just
lucky to have your presence in my life
and veronica
what have you been doing since you
became a recipient
of the dvf award oh man uh
since then we've grown quite a bit you
know it's 22. i'm a little bit older now
you know it was an interesting story of
how
empowerment plan began as a class
project of mine in college
so i was studying industrial design and
i designed the coat while i was in
school
and really designing it for people that
have been displaced
and on the streets for years and i
created it because it's something an
opportunity i wish my own family had
been given you know i grew up in a
situation
of poverty and my parents struggled with
unemployment and addiction
and mental health and creating that
opportunity
i wish could have been given to me and
my family growing up
and so you know since the dvf awards
we've distributed
about 50 000 coats across the entire us
and now 21 other countries but you see
veronica survived it
she really used it's her grandfather at
one point
who taught who spoke to her and say own
it girl
unless you get educated you're not going
anywhere this is where your life will be
and so from that moment on she went to
school
she made it her class project to create
this
code which is more than a code it's a
home
because it was made for homeless so it's
a code that's a home
and and while she was doing that she
also gave
work to homeless people to make the code
so she really went around
by her own which is what the mission of
this award is about
thank you and i appreciate it and that's
so
i'm so lucky i don't think we all
realize how lucky
we are that i had my grandfather that
could do that that could sit me down
and that i have incredible people like
dion right here
endorsing the organization and the women
that we serve
well veronica do you have any advice
like your grandfather gave to you of
where someone can start
if they would like to find that luck and
innovation for themselves
that's a really good question and i
think i see a lot of people
waiting for the perfect situation
waiting
for something to happen and i think at
this point you just can't
wait you can start there is no perfect
time
frankly the sooner you get out there and
start doing it the quicker you can learn
and i've learned so much from the
community that we work with
we would not have empowerment plan
without them and without their
incredible ideas and i also would like
to say one thing
sometimes you know you're in front of a
situation
and it's so dark it's so many people you
say
what i mean there's nothing that i could
do that can
save it because the situation is so bad
me the truth is that
all you need to do is save one person
you save one person and there's a whole
dynasty behind
okay so glad that i asked both of you
because those were very hopeful
answers and we here at the show would
love to support
um every effort that you're making
veronica
and just donate five thousand dollars to
the empowerment plan
[Applause]
thank you this is amazing the
best best zoom call i've had
[Applause]
[Laughter]
thank you for this inspired inspired
talk
and for more information about the
empowerment plan
and how you can help support go to our
website at thedrewbraymoreshow.com
and we'll shoot it to um dion's website
and we'll just lead you and guide you to
the work
that dion and veronica are doing
so thank you guys for your time